in diesem Jahr möglicherweise
historischen fluchtwinter sowie es die
experten nennen und inmitten dessen
kommt der politische Vorschlag aus der
Bundesregierung die Einbürgerung
deutlich zu beschleunigen die
Innenministerin Nancy Feser will genau
das den deutschen Pass erleichtern Herr
Müller warum wir müssen uns mal ehrlich
machen ganz jenseits von Syrien oder
Ukraine wir sind eigentlich seit
Jahrzehnten ein Einwanderungsland und
wir brauchen Einwanderung gerade auch
wegen der wirtschaftlichen Entwicklung
damit dieses Land sich positiv
weiterentwickeln kann brauchen wir
Einwanderung und Einwanderung muss auch
Regeln kennen
Staatsbürgerschaft muss Regeln kennen
und deswegen ist jetzt etwas zu
verabreden wann kann und sollte wer auch
deutscher Staatsbürger werden können
nach welcher Aufenthaltsdauer hier mit
welchen Sprachkenntnissen kann er sein
Leben alleine beschützen weniger
Sprachkenntnisse auch na die die
Bedingungen sind weiterhin da deutsche
Sprache sein Leben bestreiten können
dauerhafter Wohnsitz hier alles das ist
weiterhin Bedingung aber erleichtert
damit wir auch Zuwanderung stärker
geregelte Zuwanderung mit
Staatsbürgerschaft ermöglichen Hella
Fontaine ist das ihre Auffassung nach
eine soziale eine gute eine gute Idee
auch zur Integration so wie es die
Innenministerin ja sagt
ich stimme zu wir brauchen Einwanderung
das geben die Zahlen her
aber man muss natürlich auch sagen dass
Einwanderung immer begrenzt sein muss
das ist ja schon eine Aussage die viele
Politikerinnen und Politiker sich nicht
mehr trauen und die Einwanderung das
sieht man jetzt an der Diskussion wird
umso schwerer wenn wir in einer solchen
Situation sind wie jetzt das eben viele
Flüchtlinge kommen und dann ist sinkt
die Aufnahmen Bereitschaft der
Bevölkerung wer etwas anderes sagt hat
die letzten Jahre nicht miterlebt
insofern Einwanderung ja aber immer
begrenzt und eben der jeweiligen
Situation angepasst und wenn es also
schon um Einwanderung in das
Arbeitsleben geht möchte ich einen
Gedanken hinzufügen Einwanderung darf
nicht
missbraucht werden zum Lohndumping das
ist eine wichtige zusatzbemerkung die
man machen muss jetzt haben wir aber
über Einwanderung und über ein bürgerung
gesprochen Frau Zimmermann sie haben
von denen gesprochen hat beim Thema dass
die Aufnahmebereitschaft dann sinkt in
Deutschland das hat sie offenbar gestört
aber die Frage ganz konkret zu der
Einbürgerung also die FDP steht ja
offenbar gerade auf der Bremse in der
Koalition sie auch werden Sie mir
Gelegenheit geben sortiere ich das
gerade bitte auseinander so wir haben
jetzt diskutiert über das Thema Flucht
und Vertreibung ja das hat damit gar
nichts zu tun so das zweite also mit der
Frage Einwanderung wir haben in der Kur
im Koalitionsvertrag vereinbart dass wir
das was unter der cdu/csu jahrzehntelang
verhindert wurde weil diese Partei eben
nicht erkannter das wäre ein
Einwanderungsland sind das sind andere
Länder durchaus weiter gesagt wir müssen
Einwanderung Regeln übrigens auch in
bestimmte Berufe sei es Fachkräfte sei
es in Pflegeberufe wenn Sie heute in
Pflegeheime gehen in die Kliniken werden
wir ohne gezielte Einwanderung von
Menschen die aus anderen Ländern
gekommen sind hätten wir haben sowieso
schon ein Problem hätten wir ein
massives Problem also haben wir das
angegangen dass in bestimmten Zeiten mit
strengen Voraussetzungen ist möglich ist
einzuwandern aber eben nicht in die
sozial in die in die dass man das Geld
abfischt sondern Arbeitsmarkt in den
Arbeitsmarkt und das brauchen wir in
Deutschland angesichts der Aufgaben so
die vor uns liegen das ist das eine und
jetzt der dritte dass wir natürlich eine
Einwanderung machen müssen unter der
Voraussetzung auch dass wir diejenigen
die illegal in Deutschland sind die sich
hier nicht integrieren die
möglicherweise sogar straffällig gewesen
sind auch umgehend wieder zurückführen
Länder wünschenswert will die Mehrzahl
der Deutschen wissen Sie wie viele
aktuelle ausreisepflichtig sind in
Deutschland nicht aber können sie
schätzen ich will nicht schätzen der ist
eine ganz wichtige Zeit weil es jemand
am Tisch wenn Politiker in der Runde
sagt wir müssen gucken dass wir
schnellere Abschiebungen kriegen dann
gehört zur Realität ist im Moment
300.000 Menschen in Deutschland
ausreisepflichtig sind aber eben nicht
abgeschlossen
ungefähr 60.000
das hat erstmal einige haben eine
Duldung die können eine Zeit lang
bleiben also auch das ist ist das Leben
ist eben nicht so einfach ja das ist
extrem schwierig aber das gehört eben
zur Realität
wie Joachim stamp als migrationsminister
eben genau das in NRW gemacht hat Leute
zurückzuführen das ist bei manchen
Staaten problematisch weil die Länder
ihre eigene Leute nicht mehr annehmen
aber also Flüchtlinge gezielte
Einwanderung nach Spielregeln und so
schnell wie möglich Leute abschieben und
letzteres hat auch oft ist auch oft eine
rechtliche Frage so dass eben das mag
auf dem Papier nichts miteinander zu tun
haben so wie sie das wie sie gesagt
haben
aber wenn man wenn wir über die
Flüchtlinge sprechen die 2015/2016 zu
uns gekommen sind und wenn man dann
heute sagt okay also jetzt ist der
Zeitraum verstrichen jetzt können
könnten theoretisch all diese Menschen
deutsche werden man beschleunigt ist
sie brauchen fünf Jahre einen recht
Aufenthaltsstatus genau das ist so
ähnlich aber hat das Thema nichts
miteinander
auf der anderen Seite die Einbürgerung
wenn ich weiß natürlich schnelleres
Verfahren für den deutschen Pass ja
natürlich hat was miteinander zu tun
denn diese neuen Kriterien fünf Jahre
oder wenn jemand ehrenamtlich tätig ist
sogar noch drei Jahren und wenn Kinder
dann da sind die sind automatisch
deutsche geborene knüpft ihr an und
diejenigen die 15 16 in dieser großen
Zahl gekommen sind es knüpft ja an wir
im Sommer 2015 und dann die Fluchtwelle
ab dem ersten Wochenende september 2015
und dann jeden Tag allein bei mir und
der Wahlkreis Grenze täglich 1250 war
immer jeder Bus 50 und dann alle halbe
Stunde
die sind jetzt 7 Jahre da also die
hätten schon
feiern ins
Rheinland-Pfalz was machen sie was
machen Sie liebe Frau Zimmermann wenn
700 ja nee nee aber dies ist
das was heißt denn das Nein verliert
worden sind ja wissen Sie wie das ging
ich war ja selber dabei wenn am Bahnhof
von Salzburg sie kennenzul Salzburg z.B
700 Wahl
sie wissen genau wie die gebirgsäge in
Bad Reichenhall und Bescheid toll
darf ich das bitte
wenn am Bahnhof von Salzburg 700
Flüchtlinge im Park aufbrechen über die
Saale 2015 war das so im Oktober die
Sarah Brücke stürmen was wollen da 50
oder 40 Bundes Polizisten die Rennen
rein dann ruft mich der Bürgermeister an
und sagt Peter was soll ich tun ja sage
ich Polizei und ja wir sammeln die eh
wieder ein bisschen ein und so weiter
und dann kommen
beim aktuellen politischen und auch
über die schnelligkeiten deutschen Pass
zu bekommen ich will einfach versuchen
rauszufinden was eigentlich für uns alle
über Voraussetzung sein sollte Deutscher
zu werden was müsste für Sie welche
Bedingungen müssen wie sie erfüllt sein
für Deutschland die deutsche Sprache
muss man beherrschen man muss sein
Lebensunterhalt selbst bestreiten können
man muss hier wohnen das sind schon drei
Mindestanforderungen die zu erfüllen
sind wie steht es um die Identifikation
erreichbar ist und auch da wieder wir
unterstellen immer dass das größte Glück
für Menschen auf der Erde ist hier zu
leben und die deutsche
Staatsbürgerschaft zu bekommen die
allermeisten die auch von einer Flucht
wieder den Weg zu uns gefunden haben
wollten eigentlich in ihrem Land bleiben
möchte sind möglicherweise wir haben
sauer völlig zu Recht sagt seit 2015 die
sind jetzt sieben sechs sieben Jahre alt
Kinder sind hier Träumen Kinder gehen
hier zur Schule sprechen perfekt deutsch
die Eltern haben inzwischen einen
Arbeitsplatz gefunden haben inzwischen
eine Wohnung gefunden und nun jetzt
lassen wir mal alles mit Asyl und
Aufenthaltsrecht Weg nach dieser Zeit zu
sagen es ist für mich als Syrer jetzt
auch dieser Zeit nach diesen sieben
Jahren nachdem meine Kinder ihr geboren
sind auch ein Thema wieder auch ein
Thema deutscher werden zu können mit der
deutschen Staatsangehörigkeit was ist
daran eigentlich so verwerflich.ja das
wollte ich von Ihnen wissen wie wir
Integration bekommen und die Frage ist
wie wir die Menschen in den Arbeitsmarkt
bekommen ganz viele das wissen wir alle
Nico Elise haben eben diesen
erfolgreichen Weg nicht gegangen oder
haben ihn nicht gehen können haben eben
keine Arbeit gefunden in all diesen
Jahren wird das durch den deutschen Pass
dass es jetzt die Kernfrage leichter
angeblich geht's ja gar nicht nach einem
Villa ohne Arbeit könnte ich nicht
deutscher werden aber ich weiß nicht ob
es wirklich so hart geregelt ist und ich
glaube auch dass die Sprache
Erfordernisse herabgesenkt wurden
zumindest für alte auch für junge das
ist alles nicht mehr so das soll alles
nicht mehr so streng sein diesmal war
vorgestellt und dann empfehle ich Ihnen
mal zu lesen und sie haben sie haben
mich gelesen geführt wann sie die
Rückführungen es ist noch nicht kein
Gesetzentwurf es ist der Vorschlag aus
dem Innenministerium das ist erstmal ein
Vorschlag des Innenminister